zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
china die usa russland brasilien die eu
fast alle haben sich heute darin
übertroffen zu erklären wie wichtig
ihnen der klimaschutz ist
den hat auch us präsident joe biden als
besonders wichtig hervorgerufen bei
einem online klimagipfel zudem 40 staats
und regierungschefs eingeladen hat
international online und viele haben
eben auch zahlen vorgelegt um wieviel
bis wann sie den co2 ausstoß reduzieren
wollen aber reicht das was bringt das
darüber werden wir heute abend sprechen
unter anderem sagt pauline brünger von
files for future das bringt gar nichts
das ist viel zu wenig und damit wird sie
bundesumweltministerin svenja schulze
konfrontieren heute hier bei uns in der
sendung beide werden gleich dabei seien
aber erst einmal hören und blicken wir
in die usa und hören uns an was us
präsident joe biden heute beim gipfel
gesagt hat kein staat kann diese krise
alleine lösen das werden sie alle
verstehen wir alle und besonders die
größten wirtschaftsnationen wir müssen
uns verbessern
wir sind hier auf diesem gipfel um zu
diskutieren wie jeder von uns jedes land
höhere klimaziele festlegen kann
die im gegenzug gut bezahlte
arbeitsplätze schaffen werden
die jobs werden eine wichtige rolle
spielen darüber werden wir sprechen
heute in der sendung welches signal geht
von dieser botschaft aus dazu begrüße
ich hier im studio unseren zdf.umwelt
experten volker und in den usa in
washington unseren korrespondenten elmar
theveßen und bevor wir in die runde
einsteigen noch ganz kurz an sie alle zu
hause diskutieren sie gerne mit
schreiben sie uns ihre und eure fragen
und kommentare wie immer in die
kommentare
bei social media oder wenn ihr die app
nutzt bitte an die unten eingeblendete
e-mail-adresse immer was ist dein
eindruck ist dass heute der beginn von
etwas neuem welches signal geht von dem
aus was us präsident joe biden
da heute gesagt hat ja ich glaube schon
das ist ein ganz wichtiges signal weil
erstens zeigt amerika jetzt eben wieder
dass es bereit ist zu führen
im kampf gegen den klimawandel als
zweiter aber auch ich sag es mal ganz
salopp wie man es in meiner heimat sagen
butter bei die fische das heißt also
nicht nur die ankündigung die
co2-emissionen zu senken zu halbieren
bis zum jahr 2030 sondern auch das was
er hier schon im amerikanischen kongress
vorgelegt hat nämlich ein
infrastrukturprogramm das ja über 2,29
millionen dollar umfassen soll
das geht natürlich einerseits wunder die
um die unterstützung der wirtschaft aber
andererseits eben auch dabei dieses geld
auch zu investieren in erneuerbare
technologien beispielsweise in
elektroautos beispielsweise in lahde
sollen dann das zweit beispielsweise in
den ausbau der stromnetze um wind- und
sonnenenergie eben auch in den
hintersten winkel der usa zu bringen
also es ist ein sehr ambitioniertes
programm und das bedeutet das eigentlich
der präsident ich sag mal seinen erfolg
seine innenpolitischen erfolg verbunden
hat gleichzeitig auch mit diesen
klimazielen und das erhöht die chance
dass er es wirklich ernst meint und dass
die usa in den nächsten jahren dieses
wirklich vorantreiben werden immer
volker ihr habt zusammen nur
dokumentationen und macht die kann man
sich auch angucken über die zdf
mediathek das eine ist ja das was in
washington beschlossen und kommuniziert
und gewollt wird und das andere ist was
die amerikaner dann daraus machen was
war dein eindruck wie weit gehen die
amerikaner mit bei den klimaschutzzielen
des präsidenten ich würde es mal so
sagen ich glaube nicht dass die
amerikanische nation jetzt durchweg zu
klimaschützern geworden ist die rechnung
ist eigentlich ganz einfach wenn es neue
jobs gibt gut bezahlte jobs und nicht
nur kurzfristig sondern lebens karrieren
daraus werden können und wenn das mit
klimaschutz geht zum beispiel bei der
beim aufbau von windparks beim betreiben
von windparks beim entwickeln von
neuen techniken und technologien dann
sagen die amerikaner ist doch super da
kann man einfach geld mitverdienen also
machen wir klimaschutz so um wird glaube
ich ein schuh draus und wenn die
amerikaner das mal anfangen das ist mein
eindruck dann ziehen die das auch durch
das risiko was was ich sehe ist dass es
irgendwie in der amtsperiode von joe
biden irgendwie schwächeln könnte dass
er politisch derart gegenwind kind
kriegt das ist irgendwie ein knick das
wäre schlecht er muss es jetzt
durchziehen da muss alles rein geben
dass auch die billionen die ma eben
angesprochen hat wirklich da ankommen wo
sie gebraucht weil männer das hinkriegt
dann wird es auch eine über nächste
regierung die vielleicht eine ganz
andere ist in den vereinigten staaten
ist ganz ganz schwer haben das wieder
zurückzunehmen
wir haben hier gerade schon sehr
eindrucksvoll gesehen auch viele
windräder die du gerade angesprochen
hast ihr habt zwei rinderzüchter auch
getroffen deren ranch wir auch gerade
schon gesehen haben deren leben sich
komplett verändert hat auch durch die
transformation und wir hören mal was
eine von beiden dazu gesagt hat wir
hätten leicht verkaufen müssen um die
verluste in den schlechten jahren
auszugleichen und unsere art zu leben
hätte sich verändert
so konnten wir unseren lebensstandard
sogar noch verbessern mit hilfe der
windräder einen eindruck wie sehr
gelingt es die menschen mitzunehmen in
dem gedanken dass man davon profitieren
kann und dass wir in diesem gerade
gesehenen fall sich für die menschen
auch tatsächlich etwas zum besseren
verändert ja ich glaube der schlüssel
ist das was volker vorhin sagte es kommt
darauf an dass die leute was von haben
dass sie in zukunfts perspektiven
entstehen und diese beiden ranger rollen
und randy partie die waren für uns sehr
eindrucksvoll die haben vor ein paar
jahren wirklich keine zeit gehabt da
wäre ihre ranch beinahe untergegangen
also sie hätten sie aufgeben müssen dann
kam windräder und die haben sie auf
ihrem land stehen 35 große windturbinen
stehen da die sind natürlich nicht ihre
eigenen sondern von den großen
energiekonzernen dorthin gestellt
insgesamt bekommen sie im jahr dafür
etwa eine viertelmillion dollar also man
sieht das kann ein gutes geschäft sein
wir haben es auch in den
her gesehen dann in einem college da
werden wind techniker ausgebildet da
entstehen ja in der tat neue jobs und
das geld was die pro stunde verdienen 30
dollar liegt deutlich über dem was sonst
technologische jobs in den usa
einbringen insofern kann man jetzt
eigentlich schon sehen dass überall da
wo es vorteile gibt für die menschen sie
auch bereit sind mitzumachen nicht weil
sie denken das gilt auch für die partie
brüder
wir müssen jetzt das klima retten
sondern was gut fürs klima ist das ist
irgendwie meist auch gut fürs geschäft
und das sieht man den text als ganz
besonders und deswegen noch mal wichtig
was volker aufholen sagte der präsident
muss erfolgreich sein dass die menschen
hier erkennen es gibt neue jobs es
werden nicht mehr jobs verloren gehen
als neue jobs entstehen
das haben wissenschaftler der
princeton-universität mal durchgerechnet
sie glauben dass die mit diesem umstieg
der usa auf klimaneutralität bis 2050
das zu schaffen ist dass allein in den
ersten zehn jahren jetzt eine halbe bis
eine million jobs netto mehr entstehen
als verloren gehen und in den
folgejahren noch viel mehr als es könnte
funktionieren aber die amerikaner wissen
wirklich mit aller kraft vorantreiben
ja damit ist die frage von kanal ritter
ohne über youtube auch schon beantwortet
er fragt nämlich was amerikanische
rinder mit dem klimawandel zu tun und da
kann man aus einer antwort herauslesen
sehr viel denn die frage ist eben wie
sich alteingesessene industrien und
produktionen eben anpassen können an die
gegebenheiten auch die stellen sich ja
auch hier die fragen und da bin ich
ehrlich gesagt sehr gespannt wie das
gestell gespräch zwischen frau brünger
und frau schulze gleich verlaufen wird
denn die fragen stellen sich ja in
deutschland ganz genauso wie kann man
hier die transformation schaffen ohne
dass man jobs gefährdet im gegenteil so
dass man die menschen mitnimmt und
gleichzeitig vielleicht noch mehr jobs
entstehen und die frage ist auch wie
verkauft man das in der politik denn für
diese entscheidungen braucht man
mehrheiten und auch da habt ihr für eure
doku jemanden getroffen der das den
republikanern ganz gut verkauft dass der
klimaschutz eigentlich eine bomben sache
ist auch für die wirtschaft wir reden
mit unseren republikanischen zuhörer
nicht über klima war sondern über
wirtschaftliche
und wie amerika innovation vom antrag
wir haben der welt die luft geschickt
die elektrizität menschen zum mond
geschickt
unser land ist bereit den nächsten
innovativen durchbruch anzuführen bei
der sauberen energie immer würdest du
sagen dass die amerikaner da besonders
engagiert auch sind in der wirtschaft
weil sie auch einfach viele
naturkatastrophen erlebt haben houston
hattet ihr als beispiel in eurer doku
was hat das für einen ausschlag gegeben
für die wirtschaft zu sagen okay wir
haben gesehen was für auswirkungen der
klimawandel haben kann
wir müssen reagieren ja ich glaube das
spielt eine rolle wir waren in houston
und haben damit den menschen gerät da
hat sich eine allianz zusammen gefunden
sowohl auf der einen seite die stadt als
auch bürgerinitiativen aber dann auch
die großen energiekonzerne in houston
setzen ja große ölunternehmen wie exxon
beispielsweise oder bp und andere und
die haben sich fest vorgenommen
gemeinsam in der stadt houston dafür zu
sorgen dass man geschützt ist künftig
vor den großen stürmen
houston hat vor einigen jahren 2017 jahr
einen schweren hurrikan erlebt der fast
alles unter wasser gesetzt hat damals
ist auch eine ölraffinerie etwa zwei
meter unter wasser gekommen und vor
diesem hintergrund sagen selbst die
großen energiekonzerne wir müssen etwas
tun wp beispielsweise will bis zum jahr
2030 jetzt die öl und gasförderung um 40
prozent senken
das heißt noch lange nicht dass die
jetzt begehrt sind und komplett auf
erneuerbare energien umsteigen aber ich
glaube es ganz wichtig wenn die großen
unternehmen verstanden haben dass da
profit drinliegt und den amerikanern
geht es meistens nicht darum dass die
regierung in den vorschriften macht
sondern sie wollen die freiheit haben zu
entscheiden
um eben auch geld zu verdienen und wenn
das funktioniert wir sehen es gerade
hier bei den großen auto unternehmen in
den usa
sie haben angekündigt bis zum jahr 2030
oder 2035 ihre komplette flotte
umzustellen auf elektrische fahrzeuge
also dann ist das schon ein dicker
brocken und am ende werden sicherlich
auch die amerikaner dann bereit sein
diese autos zu kaufen umzusteigen auf
erneuerbare energien wenn es sich für
sie haben
auch wirklich rechnet vielen dank an der
stelle schon mal an dich selber nach
washington und wir machen hier im studio
weiter mit dir volker wir werden gleich
auch mit der bundesumweltministerin viel
über zahlen sprechen kannst du einordnen
wie belastbar und wie vergleichbar
diese zahlen und ziele sind von denen
heute die rede war von denen aber auch
schon auf vielen vergangenen gipfel die
rede war ja wie soll man sagen ganz
dünnes eis an der stelle wenn das ist
ein punkt der im klima kommt von paris
hätte geregelt werden sollen da steht es
jedenfalls drin nämlich dass man die
zahlen global so erhebt nach einem nach
einer selben methodik dass sie dann
tatsächlich vergleichbar werden das ist
bis jetzt nicht der fall
wir in deutschland sind es gewohnt wir
haben ein statistisches bundesamt da
wären die zahlen immer brav angeliefert
werden
wir werden geprüft da gibt es sichere
methoden das ist aber nicht der
weltstandard es gibt länder in afrika
die haben überhaupt keine statistik
einfach gar keine geschweige denn eine
über co2 wenn die sagen müssen wie viel
co2 einsparen dann fragen die halo wie
viel co2 produzieren wir überhaupt das
ist nicht bekannt so und dann muss man
noch wissen wie überhaupt co2 erhoben
wird das ist nicht messbar da läuft
keiner mit einem messgerät rum und sagt
hallo wir haben jetzt so und so viel co2
das wird hochgerechnet über den
primärenergieverbrauch also ein land
verbraucht so und so viel kohle so und
so viel öl so und so viel benzin und so
weiter und jedes mal kann man spezifisch
ausrechnen eine tonne kohle von der
sorte
denn die verbrannt wird optimal verband
wird entsteht so und so viel co2 so und
da merkt man schon wenn man das
statistisch dann abgleicht da sind jede
menge fehler drin also die zahlen sind
bestenfalls anhaltspunkte
das einzige was man tatsächlich gucken
kann nämlich den co2 anteil in der
atmosphäre parts per million teile pro
millionen das ist das einzige was
wissenschaftlich belastbar ist und das
machen die forscher auch aber nicht
länder bezogen sondern das geht nur
global da wird man nur ein gesamt werden
dann stellt man sich natürlich die frage
wie viel wert sind dann solche gipfel
ziele überhaupt das werden wir uns
gleich anschauen
mein kollege weder tigers hat
zusammengefasst um was es heute beim
gipfel ging joe biden hat also ein
ehrgeiziges ziel
bis 2030 will die usa den ausstoß an
treibhausgasen und 50 prozent gegenüber
2005 senken
der plan erfüllt eine vorgabe des
pariser klimavertrags von 2015 in denen
die usa wieder eingetreten sind
ex-präsident rampe aus dem abkommen
ausgetreten
bundeskanzlerin merkel begrüßte das neue
klimaziele
ich bin sehr froh dass die vereinigten
staaten von amerika wieder zurück in der
klimapolitik sind denn es ist ja
vollkommen unstrittig dass die welt ihr
mitwirken braucht werden wir das pariser
abkommen erfüllen wollen und der
nationale beitrag der usa drückt auch
die ambitionen aus das ist ein sehr
wichtiges zeichen für die ganze
weltgemeinschaft ein blick auf die
weltweite co2 emission macht deutlich
china stößt das meiste co2 aus gefolgt
von den usa und der eu nun verschärfen
auch die eu-mitgliedstaaten ihre ziele
bis 2030 soll der co2 ausstoß und 55
prozent gesenkt werden
im vergleich zu 1990 allerdings hat die
eu bis vergangenes jahr ihren co2
ausstoß gerade mal um rund 25 prozent
reduziert für die restlichen 30 prozent
bleiben also nicht einmal zehn jahre bis
zum jahr 2050 will die eu dann
klimaneutral sein
die runde wird hier ein bisschen größer
ich begrüße in berlin die
bundesumweltministerin svenja schulze
schön dass sie dabei sind frau schulze
und in köln pauline brünger von friday
is for future schönen guten abend auch
ihnen und danke fürs mitmachen und die
erste frage würde ich gerne an sie
richten frau schulze ist das aus ihrer
sicht ein tag der der anfang von etwas
neuem ist der tag der bewegung bringt
das ist ich glaube ich heute ein
wichtiger tag weil die usa jetzt ja
zurück sind beim klimaschutz und wenn
man sich anguckt wie das in den letzten
jahren war dann waren wir auf dem weg zu
einer erhitzung von 3,5 grad das ist ein
szenario das will ich mir gar nicht
ausmalen
so und jetzt sind wir auf dem weg 2%
erhitzung zwei grad erhitzung zu haben
und
das 1,5 grad ziel fest im blick und das
ist eine deutliche veränderung und
deswegen bin ich sehr froh über diese
ankündigungen der usa und hoffe dass
jetzt viele folgen also die usa europa
hat vorgelegt jetzt kommt die usa und
viele viele weitere haben ja jetzt auch
schon angekündigt dass sie mehr tun
wollen
das ist wirklich wichtig frau brünger
wie optimistisch sind sie dass dieser
tag tatsächlich eine veränderung einen
neuanfang beinhaltet
ich glaube man muss zuallererst sagen
die ziele die jetzt neu festgelegt
worden sind das sind keine ziele die mit
dem co2 budget vereinbar sind dass uns
bleibt für 15 grad und 15 grad das ist
ja keine zeile wir uns ausgedacht haben
sondern das ist an sich schon der
historische kompromiss so sehr darf sich
die erde erhitzen und dann ist das für
die menschen nicht mehr tragbar war
svenja schulze gerade gesagt hat dass
wir uns jetzt auf ein limit von 2 grad
an jan ich glaube da muss man einfach
auch noch sagen die ziele die in den
letzten tagen ausgesprochen wurden wofür
sich gross gelobt wurde das sind auch
chile wo ganz viel bilanzen
schöngerechnet worden sind wo ist
rechentricks gab und ich glaube man kann
ja auch nicht von der sicherheit
sprechen dass wir überhaupt diese zwei
grad gerade einhalten können und ich
glaube es ist eine riesige gefahr dass
sozusagen das untergeht in dem versuch
von regierungschef sich in diesen tagen
selber zu logen den klimaschutz aber
eigentlich wieder hinten anstellen
wollen und nur symbolpolitik walten zu
lassen
frau schulze sie dürfen gerne direkt
antworten ist das mehr als symbolpolitik
was da passiert ist oder ist es
tatsächlich ich meine man erlebt dass er
selber man es so verwirrt von all diesen
zielen die immer wieder auf diesen
gipfeln groß verkündet werden und am
ende weiß man nicht genau was davon
es sei denn man beschäftigt sich so sehr
mit der sache wie frau brünger aber was
davon am ende bringt uns denn
tatsächlich dahin wo wir hin müssen um
diesen planeten nicht unrecht zu tun
ich glaube das ist deutlich mehr als im
monat politik was wir da gerade sehen
das ist eine wirkliche umsteuerung in
unserer gesellschaft wir sehen das in
deutschland bei den reduktionen die wir
haben da stehen reale strukturelle
veränderungen dahinter wer die
kohlekraftwerke werden abgeschaltet wir
setzen auf erneuerbare energie
anders sah die wirtschaft die
gesellschaft alle müssen mitmachen
aber das passiert doch gerade auch es
ist viel viel breiter in der
gesellschaft angekommen als jemals zuvor
sehr viele auch aktive aus der
wirtschaft machen mit aus der
gesellschaft sowieso und es muss
umgesteuert das geht nicht von heute auf
morgen das geht nicht von einem tag auf
den anderen
aber die nächsten zehn jahre sind die
entscheiden und ich sehe dass sich da
deutlich mehr getan hat in der letzten
zeit und dass wir da auf dem weg sind
der mich jedenfalls optimistisch stimmt
volker dich auch teil optimistisch also
was man auf der internationalen ebene
jetzt sagen kann dass dieses buhmann
spiel vorbei ist also bis jetzt auf den
klimakonferenzen frau schulze weiß dass
wir haben uns da oft genug getroffen war
es immer so werden wir nichts macht da
drüben in china oder in russland machen
die amerikaner auch nichts und dann ging
es immer so kreis rum und da haben sich
gegenseitig ausgebremst das geht ab
heute nicht mehr
die amerikaner haben klar gesagt sie
wollen führung übernehmen
führungsanspruch machen sie geltend beim
klimaschutz
was man sagen kann ok das reicht nicht
für das 1,5 grad limit ist eine andere
frage das ist im moment tatsächlich so
und es wird aber auch noch schlimmer
frau schulze die ir die internationale
energieagentur hat vor zwei tagen
bekanntgegeben dass in diesem jahr der
co2 ausstoß noch mal locker um fünf
prozent ansteigt warum weil zwar wir aus
der kohle aussteiger was china nicht
erst viel viel später da geht es doch
richtig los der pandemie effekt ist
durch die wirtschaft brummt wieder
und dummerweise läuft das in china immer
noch über kohlekraftwerke
da sind jahre lang nicht genutzt werden
weil sich eben china und die usa
dauerhaft blockiert haben und
gegenseitig immer gewartet haben bis der
eine den ersten schritt tut jetzt kann
man die hoffnung haben dass das durch
ist das gute signal ist ja dass die
chinesen mitmachen in einem arbeitskreis
der mag zwar erst auf dem papier stehen
und immer ganz nass aber so ist
internationale klimapolitik das geht
nicht so schnell wie frei des for future
sich das vorstellt und wie uns also das
wünschen
es ist ein langsamer prozess aber wir
haben noch gar nicht über die
afrikanischen staaten gesprochen
das wäre eine eigene sendung werden
angesprochen
china und die usa bilden eine neue klima
allianz es gibt einen amerikanisch
chinesischen arbeitskreis frau schulze
das ist was was sich die eu schon lange
wünscht und was auch immer wieder auch
von der eu-kommission betont wurde dass
man da in der zusammenarbeit unbedingt
miteinander sein will haben die chinesen
europa da jetzt überholt dann wir sind
in guten kooperation auch auf der
europäischen ebene von europa aus mit
china es war ja ein ganz wichtiges
signal dass nach den letzten gesprächen
die wir von europäischer seite mit china
geführt haben china angekündigt hat das
ziel was sie erreichen wollen zu erhöhen
und es gibt nur zusammen
die usa china europa alle zusammen
müssten zeigen dass sie es ernst meinen
dass sie co2 reduzieren dass sie die
wirtschaft die gesellschaft komplett
umstellen und dass sie mit den
technologien die wir haben dass wir
damit auch denen helfen die diese
technologien brauchen die sie nicht
selber entwickeln können also das
zusammen das kommt jetzt viel stärker in
gang als jemals zuvor und es ist absolut
notwendig das geht nur zusammen das ist
wie im normalen leben auch wenn man
sieht wo der andere macht auch was dann
traut man sich auch selber wieder mehr
zu und das ist genau die dynamik die das
pariser klimaschutzabkommen entfalten
wollte ich würde gerne eine frage aus
dem chat von einem user oder einer
userin ich weiß es nicht genau namens
guss die über youtube weitergeben an
frau brünger der der oder die userin
schreibt im kapitalismus ist wachstum
notwendig sonst gäbe es krise und das
bedeutet zunahme bei der warenproduktion
und jede ware zerstört umwelt also ist
dann quasi der schluss ist grüner
kapitalismus nicht möglich frau brünger
sagen sie ja doch das geht im gegenteil
oder was antworten sie da also lustig
antwortete sofort auf deine frage ich
möchte nur ganz kurz auf zwei sachen
eigentlich noch eingehen die mir ebenso
aufgestoßen sind in dem gespräch einmal
frau schulze sie haben noch mal von dem
co2 budget eigentlich gesprochen und ich
glaube da und davon dass wir jetzt große
schritte gehen und ich
aber natürlich kann man sagen wir gehen
große schritte wenn man sich anschaut
wie katastrophal die lager vorher war
aber trotzdem ist das natürlich nur ein
winzig kleiner schritt in richtung von
ausreichender klimapolitik und das ist
glaube ich schon nichts wofür man sich
feiern kann und dann auch die beiden
beispiele die sie genannt haben haben
mich total erstaunt also das sprechen
sie einmal vom ausbau der erneuerbaren
der durch ihre regierung in den letzten
monaten und in den letzten jahren
komplett blockiert wird sie sprechen vom
kohleausstieg wo kanzlerin angela merkel
heute noch in ihrer rede auf beiden
klimagipfel stolz von einem
kohleausstieg bis 20 38 gesprochen hat
uns doch allen klar ist dass wir bis
20.30 aus der kohle raus sein müssen und
dass es dafür auch sicherheit geben muss
dass das nicht nur über den europäischen
emissionshandel laufen kann und ich
glaube so zu sagen da werden sachen
verdreht die so hinten und vorne nicht
zusammen passen und es braucht auf jeden
fall systemischen wandel und es braucht
ein wandel der jetzt anfängt emission zu
reduzieren weil wie gesagt es gibt
dieses budget wir dürfen es nicht
überschreiten wird haben wir noch eine
bestimmte menge an emissionen die wir
imitieren dürfen die in der atmosphäre
landen dürfen
und nochmal auf die frage aus dem chat
einzugehen
tatsächlich haben wir gesehen emissionen
sind bis jetzt hauptsächlich dann
gesunken wenn auch das
wirtschaftswachstum gesunken ist und das
gibt natürlich zu denken
ich glaube am ende muss bei einigen klar
sein wir brauchen erstmal verlässlich
eine zusage für 15 grad und wir brauchen
eine verlässliche zusage von allen
parteien für 1,5 grad ist es gerade
etwas was nicht vorhanden ist frau
schulze auch die spd hat kein 15 grad
kommt vors wahlprogramm vorgelegt und
dann muss ich natürlich jetzt bei dieser
bundestagswahl durchsetzen welche von
diesen konzepten sind am ende die
überzeugendsten und da ist aber bisher
ein faires spielfeld eigentlich und ich
glaube dass es auf jeden fall aber auch
eine wichtige frage die gestellt werden
muss kann das im kapitalismus möglich
sein und da warten wir gerade auf die
konzepte der parteien frau schulte muss
der kohleausstieg nach dem was frau
brunner gesagt hat doch noch mal neu
verhandelt werden weil man es bis 2030
schaffen muss wie viele es for future
fordert weil man sonst die ziele gar
nicht erreichen kann
da ist man stimmt es nicht dass nichts
passiert ist das kann man einfach nicht
sagen sondern es ist eine ganze menge
passiert die stimme zu dass wir
schneller werden müssen dass wir den
nächsten zehn jahren eher erreichen
wissen aber dass wir es geschafft haben
in seiner kohle kommission ein
kompromiss hinzubekommen und den
kohleausstieg in einem
gesellschaftlichen frieden hinzubekommen
ohne große demonstration mit hilfen für
die region mit perspektiven für die
region
ich halte das für ganz wichtig in einer
demokratie dass man solche kompromisse
solche aushandlungsprozess auch wirklich
macht und der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energie
der ist voran gekommen weil spd und
grüne mit dem erneuerbaren energien
gesetz das überhaupt erst ermöglicht
haben dass die energie heute so weltweit
erhältlich ist wie sie das ist also es
hat sich in den letzten jahren was
verändert und ich halte nichts davon
immer zu sagen
lohnt sich überhaupt nicht darüber zu
reden weil ist sowieso nicht genug wir
müssen an dazu bringen noch mehr zu
machen und es geht nur indem man
positive bilder schafft indem man mit
zieht in dem man motivieren deswegen ist
der tag heute wichtig weil die usa
wieder mit dabei sind weil china gesagt
hat dass sie mehr tun wollen japan sind
eine ganze reihe starten die heute
zusagen gemacht habe weil wir in der eu
das klimaziel erhöht haben und mein
großes maßnahmenpaket erarbeiten um
dieses ziel auch zu erreichen
das ist deutlich mehr als nichts das
sind die richtigen perspektiven und auch
die wirtschaft schaltet um
ich will dass die erneuerbaren energien
der zukunft mit grünem star mit co2
freien stahl produziert werden und dafür
muss stahl produziert werden können
und dafür brauchen wir mehr stahl der
co2 frei ist als wm heute haben und ja
das ist ein wachstum aber eins das
sinnvoll und nachhaltig ist ich muss
einfach immer einklinken david antworten
weil mein punkt ist nicht dass nichts
passiert sondern mein punkt ist dass es
hier nicht um die meinung von
einzelpersonen geht es geht ja auch
nicht darum was möchte beides for future
für klimaziele erreicht
sondern und einhalten sondern es geht
darum was ist die wissenschaftliche
grundlage davon dass geht darum wie viel
emissionen dürfen wir noch ausstoßen bis
zu einem kommen und nicht mehr
sichergestellt ist dass es für menschen
auf dieser welt eine stabile nahrungs
und wasserversorgung gibt das sehen wir
schon heute
es geht um punkt wo ich nicht mehr sagen
kann dass ich weiß dass meine zukunft
gesichert ist und das ist eben ein
physikalisches problem das ist eine
wissenschaftliche tatsache und da lässt
sich eben damit lassen sich eben doch
nicht die kompromisse machen und wir
sind uns ja einig darin dass ich etwas
bewegen muss natürlich und wir sind uns
auch einig darin dass ich alles
umstellen muss aber ich glaube wir
können nicht weiter darüber reden und
sagen ein bisschen ist mehr als gar
nichts sondern wir müssen zu dem punkt
kommen
wie schaffen wir es 15 grad umzusetzen
und ich finde sie entziehen sich hier
ihrer verantwortung und das ist also das
macht mich total sprachlos auch die
ganzen den ganzen tag heute schon wenn
ich mir anhöre was regierungschefs heute
auf diesem gipfel verkünden
dann würde ich gerne in die gelegenheit
geben frau schulze zu 100 tatsächlich
aber mit einer konkreten fragen mit
lippenbekenntnissen haben wir uns jetzt
wirklich lange genug beschäftigt
kohleausstieg vor 20 38 wird das noch
mal neu verhandelt weil es anders gar
nicht zu schaffen ist wird der
kohleausstieg 2030 kommen oder
vielleicht irgendwann dazwischen wird
das neu aufgedröselt so erstmal klar es
sind wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse aber
wir brauchen politische lösungen dafür
es muss er in den gesellschaften
umgesetzt werden und das passiert im
moment und das ist der entscheidende
punkt des heutigen tages und der
entscheidende punkt dessen was wir in
der eu jetzt höhere ziele haben usa und
china
mit dabei sind das finde ich das darf
man überhaupt nicht unterschätzen was
das für eine dynamik auslöst und sind es
lippenbekenntnissen 1
wir haben schon eine enorme reduktion
erreicht wir haben ein klimagesetz in
deutschland was uns feste vorgaben macht
wie viel co2 jedes jahr überhaupt
ausgestoßen werden darf was ein fester
mechanismus hat
wenn das nicht passiert und der
kohleausstieg der ist vereinbart da sind
auch zeiträume wo immer wieder evaluiert
wird und mit
dem neuen eu klimaziel wird kohle
ausstieg schneller gehen das ist
vollkommen klar wir werden nach meinen
schätzungen 20 30 durch sein mit der
kohle aber wie man aussteigt aus der
kohle dann muss man alternativen haben
und deswegen muss der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien jetzt noch mal
schneller gehen deswegen müssen wir da
wo es möglich ist solaranlagen auf die
dächer deswegen muss da wo flächen sind
erneuerbare energien ausgebaut werden
das ist das was uns jetzt in deutschland
gelingen muss und wo wir schneller
werden müssen
volker angres wir sehen eine ministerin
die sagt wir sind schon da und wir sehen
eine aktion ist ihm gesagt wir sind aber
erst da was sagst du wo stehen wir
ich glaube der widerspruch entsteht
einfach dadurch dass man natürlich sagt
was die wissenschaft uns schon längst
aufgetragen hat das wissen wir aber die
politischen realitäten das ist das
andere da geht es um soziale fragen
da geht es um wirtschaftliche fragen
wenn man aus der kohle aussteigt dann
kopiert man damit unternehmen die bis
dahin ihr geld damit verdient haben und
viele jobs geschaffen haben das kann man
nicht von heute auf morgen abschalten
da muss wirklich einer sagen ja was denn
dann wenn man das macht und von daher
gesehen wäre ich politiker ich würde die
finger davon lassen diesen kohle
ausstiegsplan zu kippen warum weil er
nämlich von selber kommt in dem maße wo
die grünen energien der umstieg in die
erneuerbaren diese energieformen immer
gemacht und das frau schulze müssen sie
weiter durchsetzen
herr altmaier hat gerade gesagt der die
eeg-umlage 20 23 24 maximal nur noch 50
cent das ist immer noch zu viel das muss
auf null cent runter gehen damit da auch
eine soziale entlastung stattfindet und
dann werden wir erleben dass der
kohlestrom und der co2 preis kopf nach
oben drauf eines tages so teuer kommt
dass keiner mehr lust hat sein
kohlekraftwerk anzuwerfen
das wusste die strategie der politik
sein und ein letztes noch grüner star
das geht mit grünem wasserstoff ja den
kann man hier herstellen ist er noch
teuer ist sehr umständlich da sehe ich
neue partnerschaften mit den ländern wo
es viel sonne gibt wo man das einfach
über photovoltaik zum beispiel machen
kann da müssten schon längst die schwer
unterwegs sein und sagen okay welche
neuen länder konstellation gibt es wo
können wir neue partnerschaften
hinkriegen um das voranzutreiben
wasserstoff grüner wasserstoff ist eine
schlüssel technologie um die
energiewende hin zu kriegen ich würde
gerne eine abschlussrunde einläuten und
frau brünger sie fragen
seit dieser woche haben die grünen eine
kanzlerkandidatin und jüngsten umfragen
zufolge stehen die grünen sogar vor der
cdu und weit vor vielen oder allen
anderen parteien wie groß ist ihre
hoffnung dass es im herbst eine
bundesregierung geht mit einer grünen
bundeskanzlerin die dann auch das so
vertritt wie sie es sich vorstellen
würden also ich glaube so zuerst mal
meine hoffnung ist nicht dass wir am
ende eine grüne bundeskanzlerin haben
sondern meine hoffnung ist dass wir am
ende eine regierung haben die insgesamt
1 15 grad konformen koalitionsvertrag
abgeschlossen hat und bis jetzt sind wir
an dem punkt dass keine der parteien ein
parteiprogramm vorgelegt hat das mit 1,5
grad mit diesem limit mit dieser grenze
vereinbar ist
und das muss sich ändern da müssen auch
die grünen rahmen und natürlich ein
zweiter punkt wir wissen das haben wir
in den letzten zwei jahren gemerkt
klimapolitisch kann sich was bewegen
aber es bewegt sich immer nur dann wenn
das von der gesellschaft eine
zivilgesellschaft von uns aktiv
eingefordert wird und ich glaube da darf
man auch die grünen nicht aus der
verantwortung lassen
die vermeintlich sozusagen die
klimaschutz partei sind auch wenn die an
der regierung sind
und davor natürlich muss dieser protest
weitergehen weil ansonsten habe ich
wenig hoffnung dass ich noch was ändert
ich glaube wir die klimabewegung auf der
straße das ist die größte hoffnung die
gerade für das einzige machen gerade mit
noch da ist frau schulze an schon welche
frage jetzt kommt er natürlich haben sie
auch die meldungen heute gesehen
es gibt eine umfrage für die
wirtschaftswoche demnach wurde gefragt
wer sich denn in der wirtschaft welchen
kanzler kann dir welche kanzler wünscht
unter den jetzt auf dem tableau
bestehenden kandidaten am wenigsten
zustimmung erhält hier der kandidat
ihrer partei nämlich olaf scholz mit
10,5 prozent dann kommt herr laschet und
die kandidatinnen die sich die deutsche
wirtschaft nach dieser umfrage am
meisten wünscht ist annalena baerbock
von den grünen was sagen sie dazu
das ist jetzt eine momentaufnahme sie
ist jetzt gerade frisch sozusagen
verkündet worden
ich bin davon überzeugt dass wir eben
laufe dieses wahlkampfes als spd zeigen
werden dass der richtige kann
dathe olaf scholz ist das dass derjenige
ist der mit einer zentralen zukunfts
mission mit einem zentralen plan für
deutschland zeigen kann wie wir unsere
gesellschaft modernisieren und der auch
hier dass sie nicht seiner
umweltministerin
ja natürlich weil er hat das gezeigt er
kann sich das in hamburg ansehen was
sehr für den fortschritt von hamburg
alles voran gebracht hat und ich bin mir
bei olaf scholz sehr sicher dass der
klimaschutz so macht das auch dass das
sozial fair ist dass er die menschen
mitnimmt und dass sie ja die
arbeitsplätze in der wirtschaft damit
voran bringen und diesen dreiklang diese
nachhaltigkeit die brauchen wir und das
wird wohl auf scholz nach vorne bringen
das sieht man dass er das kann er hat es
in dieser regierung gezeigt und er wird
es auch als kanzler zeigen können dann
sage ich an die beiden damen schon mal
vielen herzlichen dank svenja schulze
und pauline brünger vielen dank fürs
angeregte miteinander diskutieren und
das teilnehmen an unserer sendung vielen
dank an dieser stelle und volker ich
frage dich jetzt nicht nach deiner
perspektive was die kanzlerkandidaten
würzen
aber natürlich ist eine frage welche
rolle spielt der klimaschutz egal welche
koalition wir dann erleben werden aber
auch jetzt im wahlkampf was glaubst du
wir haben langsam so ein bisschen das
gefühl wir kommen aus der korona krise
ein ein bisschen raus zumindest ist das
im moment der hoffnungsschimmer werden
klimapolitische themen in diesem
wahlkampf wieder mehr eine rolle spielen
und was glaubst du welche akzente
könnten die parteien
da setzen ich denke dass überhaupt keine
partei an knackigen klimaschutz aussagen
vorbeikommt außer afd die glauben ihr
ohnehin nicht dass es einen
menschengemachten klimawandel gibt da
wird auch nix im parteiprogramm zu
finden sein
keine andere partei kann sich mehr
leisten das thema nicht aufzugreifen
ob es letztendlich wahl entscheidend ist
das ist die frage wir kommen aus einer
pandemie und bis zum herbst ist sie
vielleicht einigermaßen im griff wir
werden sehen dass wir extreme
wirtschaftliche probleme bekommen werden
wir brauchen ja nur in die städtische
gucken der einzelhandel einer nach dem
anderen muss konkurs anmelden weil es
einfach nicht mehr geht die große
industrie ächzt und kann sich vielleicht
gerade noch so über die runden retten es
gibt kurzarbeit das heißt ja auch ein
kommt es verluste bei den menschen die
einfach nicht mehr wissen wo sie ihr
geld hernehmen sollen bin ich ganz
sicher ob es nur der klimawandel ist da
kommen viele andere punkte dann zusammen
geschickt muss man es machen um all
diese schönen themen zu verknüpfen und
eben einen grünen kapitalismus
hinzukriegen der eben massiv soziale
aspekte mit berücksichtigt ob das die
grünen leisten können sie stehen für
klimaschutz nicht wirklich bisher wird
für soziale fragen auch nicht wirklich
für wirtschaftswachstum grünes
wirtschaftswachstum da müssen sie alle
nachlegen und auf der anderen seite die
schwarzen die roten genau andersrum
fußballgucken kommt auch darauf an wie
nachher eine mögliche koalition aussieht
und möglicherweise treffen sich dann ja
die westhoff perspektiven der
verschiedenen parteien in einer neuen
koalition das wünsche ich jedenfalls
unserem land zu sein und ihnen liebe
userinnen und user vielen dank fürs
mitmachen und mitdiskutieren und
zuschauen bis zum nächsten mal